ghost in the shell' the 1995 version was
directed by Mamoru Oshii the director of
the unseen possibly anime masterpiece
angels egg if you've never seen that
check it out it's trippy as hell this
film was based off the manga by Masamune
Shiro and takes place in the year 2029
in a world where humans and technology
have become sort of mixed in this
somewhat tangible future your
consciousness is known as a ghost and
this ghost can then inhabit a shell or
your body many people during this time
have replaced limbs or even their entire
body with cybernetic parts but as long
as you still have your ghost aka your
consciousness you're still considered
yourself you can also hack into this
realm that's known as the net which is
far more advanced and vast than even
today's internet let alone 1995's
internet it's a place where people can
actually exist which is where the puppet
master comes into play the puppet master
is the antagonist of this film it's a
sentient life-form that was born in the
vast sea of information as it describes
itself and this entity is hacking into
things and causing a lot of problems for
section 9 which is a police force of
sorts led by major Motoko Kusanagi who
is a cyborg herself but still maintains
a ghost of some form of humanity I
believe the first time I ever heard of
ghost in the shell' was actually on
Siskel and Ebert Japanese animation or
anime is the fastest growing underground
cult in the movie world even though the
sleek and high-tech animated movies from
Japan rarely surfaced in conventional
theaters every year a few of them break
through however and the new anime
feature making the rounds now is ghost
in the shell' but this was during what a
lot of people called the japanimation
era and i did an entire video on that
era on my retro rewind segment this is
when anime was starting to creep into
america and it was becoming more popular
here and you could get it in small
little groups you would sometimes see it
in comic book stores and I would
commonly see that exact VHS of ghost in
the shell' at my neighborhood comics
store JC comics and cards and I never
got to see this film until I was a
little bit older and I would say it
actually took me about four or five
viewings to fully appreciate
just how special this film is and since
the new ghost in the shell' film
starring Scarlett Johansson is coming
out very soon I thought it would be a
great time to talk about the original
film that started it all this film was
highly influential on quite a bit of
American entertainment most notably Dark
City the Alex Proyas film and the matrix
the Wachowskis film the opening titles
of ghost in the shell' used a green font
that was very much so recreated in the
matrix code as well as the idea of
hacking into an unseen world that then
could be accessed and you could actually
move around in it as an environment and
in both films that was done by
connecting something to the back of your
neck you can watch this film purely on
an entertainment level and enjoy the
great animation which was a seamless
blend of cel animation and CG animation
you can enjoy the great action sequences
and the amazing score by Kenji Kawai but
there is so much more under the surface
of ghost in the shell' that as I said
took me about four or five viewings to
truly fully appreciate and that's some
of the stuff I want to talk to you guys
about in this video this film in such a
short runtime masterfully explores the
difference between humanity and
technology what is it that separates the
two what happens when the two begin to
merge can a sentient life form that is
artificial be considered a human what is
it that makes a human being a human
being can something that was created be
considered human can something that
feels as if it is human be considered
human what is the exact ingredient that
makes us people and this is something
that's explored and ghost in the shell'
in such a beautiful and
thought-provoking way we see the
character of Morocco Kusanagi being
created we understand that she is fully
cybernetic but her ghost remains and
it's this ghost this fleeting little
aura of humanity that still exists in
her that makes her curious in one
beautiful sequence she gazes out at
people who are going shopping at the
city and architecture around her and she
appears overwhelmed by everything she's
clearly very curious about what humanity
is and how close to it she is if she is
human or is she not there are sequences
where she tests her limits
she goes swimming one time to see what
that feels like and one Bato her partner
is like hey aren't you worried that you
might sink to the bottom or something
she's like no because when I'm down
there I feel fear
I feel anxiety I even feel hope when
she's down there she feels like she's
touching an essence of humanity that she
doesn't feel otherwise
so clearly this character is someone who
is unsure of herself which brings me to
another very important aspect of this
movie that hasn't been talked about too
much but has been explored in some
analyses of ghost in the shell' and that
is gender identity
Kusanagi clearly does not consider her
form from a sexual perspective she will
often disrobe wearing a skin-tight suit
that allows her to use therm up to
camouflage and she'll sometimes be
walking around like that without even
noticing that others might be looking at
her in a sexual way
Bato her partner clearly is slightly
more human than her because as he looks
at her he feels the need to clothe her
instantly there's even a sequence after
she goes swimming where he sees her
begin to take off her swimsuit and he
feels the need to look away so does this
mean that Bato is more human than modak
oh or simply that moto Co does not
identify as a female or even as a human
anymore and what I love the most about
ghost in the shell' is that it does not
have a definitive answer for any of
these questions you can watch the film
and you can overanalyze it to death but
in the end a lot of these questions are
unanswered and it leaves you feeling
this sense of euphoria because you've
just experienced such a
thought-provoking film in like 82
minutes or something in animation form
and it gives you all these questions to
ponder about so the puppetmaster as I
said this was a consciousness that was
born from the sea of information that's
how it describes itself in the film so
what I can assume is that this thing
somehow was just born on the net
somewhere and was wondering what it is
so it tries to ghosts hack other people
which means getting inside of their head
and essentially recreating their
memories and figuring out what exactly
makes a person a person this entity is
grappling with what makes a human a
human is it mortality the inevitable
fact that we will die or is it that we
can reproduce and create life because
there's a sequence where
Kusanagi is like yeah but you can copy
yourself and create other versions of
yourself and he's like a copy is just
the pale imitation reproduction is
actually creation it's all of these
philosophical questions combined with
the technical prowess on display that
make ghost in the shell' one of the best
animated films ever conceived the
animation is stunning the character
models and the way they move is very
realistic the action sequences are
enthralling
the musical score as I already said is
one of the best in anime history
everything was so meticulously crafted
in this film to create such an impactful
experience right down to just motor co
eyes they rarely ever blink in this
movie and this wasn't just because of
laziness it was because they really
wanted her to seem more like a doll or a
cyborg and it works extremely well
because as you watch the film you
genuinely feel a disconnect with her and
it's that disconnect that she feels with
society that is so well reflected just
through imagery you don't even
necessarily need dialogue of her
explaining how she feels to understand
that Kusanagi is incredibly unclear
about her existence and feels torn
between humanity and technology as
already stated ghost in the shell' has
had a humongous cultural impact that is
still being felt today it's a fantastic
animation film it's one of the best I
think ever made it's extremely
thought-provoking but it's also very
entertaining on a popcorn level I'm
gonna give ghost in the shell' an A+ the
new film has a lot to live up to let's
hope it's good because if it's not we
might have another Dragonball Evolution
on our hands so since the new film is
coming out this is the perfect
opportunity to talk about ghost in the
shell' to innocence Mamoru Oshii sequel
and we're going to do that very soon
look forward to that guys thank you so
much as always for watching have you
ever seen ghost in the shell' what are
your thoughts on this film let me know
below and as always if you liked this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you